sign-in with Apple was a feature
announced by Apple and 2019 and it
allows users to authenticate into a web
or mobile application using their Apple
ID it works just like other one-click
social sign-in methods like Google
Facebook Twitter etc to implement this
method in your firebase app you'll first
need to have an Apple Developer account
which will run you about $99 per year
now head over to your Apple developer
portal create a new app ID or update an
existing one to use the sign-in with
Apple capability from there you'll
create a new service ID and configure it
to work with your domain enter the
hosting URLs from your firebase project
then register the service ID now we need
to verify ownership of this domain with
Apple go back to the configuration for
the service ID you'll see the option to
download a file save that file under the
well-known directory in your public
hosting folder then upload this file to
firebase hosting by running firebase
deploy from the command line click
verify and you should get a green check
mark now the last thing we need is a
private key click on keys and then
generate a new one for Apple sign-in go
ahead and download this file somewhere
securely on your system then open it in
your editor at this point we can go to
the authentication tab on the firebase
console and click enable for Apple
sign-in enter your team ID as well as
the information from the private key and
now we just need to add a little bit of
JavaScript to our front-end app with
firebase initialized we'll make a
reference to auth then we'll define an
async function called sign in with Apple
it instantiates an auth provider for
apple calm then awaits the auth sign in
with pop-up method this prompts the user
to login with their Apple ID and when
they're done they'll be logged into the
firebase app and will have access to
their user data on the result this has
been Apple sign-in with firebase in 100
seconds and I realize that was super
fast so head over to fire ship IO to get
a full step-by-step breakdown of the
process thanks for watching make sure to
LIKE and subscribe and I will see you in
the next one